madison square guard i mean things have
just gone so well for you it's exciting
yeah these these tours you're doing are
so popular the latest one the tour is
called 50. yes sir you uh you are 50 are
you are you feeling different right now
is it 50 yeah
no i turned 50 and i just decided to
call to tour that
i'm kind of going the opposite of all
the people who do like the botox
and the hair plugs and trying to look 22
for the rest of their life right you
know when they really just you know they
they don't look good yeah you know
you're saying why don't fake it just
embrace it embrace make your eyes water
when you look at them
my wife's always watching like those
real housewives and stuff and they just
look exhausted
they're like in there you know it always
reminds me of remember when brett favre
played on the vikings yeah
it was just like just retire dude you're
in the hall of fame yeah yeah it's over
and those women it's like yeah you had
your time you were beautiful and it's
over
some people groan you don't remember
when you were a kid you went to the club
and there was that older person hanging
out
that creep
yeah that's what you're doing that's
what you're doing 50 is not the new 40.
it's 50.
all right i have to go see doctors yeah
i have to have blood taken
so i feel i feel young physically but
mentally like when i watch tv it makes
me feel old what makes you feel old
about watching tv
ah this well music there's no guitar
solos anymore and then for some reason
with all this technology millennials if
you take a full water bottle and you
flip it in the air and it lands upright
they run out of the room like they just
saw a witch
everybody's like oh
they just they just take off it's like
really you had virtual reality glasses
on you're playing all these video games
and all somebody has to do i mean that's
like a game like tom sawyer would have
played
so it's stuff like that that i'm just
like i'm not
i'm not ridiculing it it's just like wow
i can't relate to this you can't relate
to it yeah you know your show f is for
family i relate to it because it's about
parenting in the 70s and that's you know
that was when i was parented like you
what do you think of parents now how do
you compare them to parents in the 70s
oh it's just completely the kids have so
much power it's like ridiculous like
half of these kids i'm like i look and i
just have what happened to me and i'm
like looking at a kid and be like this
kid's about me to get punted across the
grocery store and it just never happens
right they just
they just don't get hit
and i think it's hurting you
you're a man wait a minute
it's not like he's got this
you're mad that children are not being
uh this should be the threat of it
half of it it was just that look it was
just your dad was acting like he was
gonna do it he never did it but your
mother did and because
because she was still because she was a
woman it was like okay because it was
like hey you let a girl beat you up you
kind of felt emasculated yeah
we had a ruling like i actually a lot of
the stuff that i look at from when i was
a kid that actually kind of made sense
in a way is now would now be considered
like abuse i guess like when i was a kid
if you didn't finish your supper as we
called it supper yeah yeah my mother was
just like well you're gonna finish she
would just wrap it in cellophane and you
just picked up where you left off for
breakfast like like a blue-collar job
like you take the shovel out of the hole
and just start digging it again
so
yeah i remember one night we had cube
steaks
which is like one of the toughest pieces
of meat i don't know if you guys
everything's so like
asian infused wagyu beef everybody's
eating that crap now but cube's steak
was like they had literally had to hit
it with a hammer
to make it like edible
and uh so we were having cube steaks and
i figured my little brother was still in
a high chair and he couldn't finish his
so my mother goes all right we're just
gonna have to eat it for breakfast and
that was like eight hours away which was
like half his life so he's like all
right i'll take that deal
so the next morning
we remember we were having waffles my
mother always made sunday breakfast so
we had all these waffles eggs bacon this
whole layout my brother was looking at
half-eaten cube
steaks and a little mound of green bean
casserole and he goes so he looked at my
mom and goes mom can i have a waffle
and she goes no you got to finish your
supper
he's like well
after i finish my wolf supper then can i
have a waffle she goes no that is your
breakfast and he goes oh mom i hate you
and my dad without looking up took a
full glass of milk and threw it in his
face
swear to god
this is what kills me
we're killing everyone today to have as
miserable a childhood as you had
no but it was kind of funny
i just we know what's hilarious was my
mother just popped up and just
immediately started cleaning up and my
dad just kept eating like he didn't like
like the rolls were defined back then
now the guy has to throw the milk he has
to clean it up while telling his wife
she's brave for just sitting there
like whatever that is that you hear it
oh oh i know
women are so
overrated right we went through tonight
what we went
we went from not listening to them to
now it's just it's just you know it's
just it's it's ridiculous like that
believe women it's like all of them
how about how about 85 i'll give you 87
all right
but that last 13 that keys your car
lights your [ __ ] on fire and puts a
family pet in a in a pot of stew
who put a pen and a pot of stew
glenn clothes
that's yeah okay all right i think it
was a separate you know what i miss i
miss yeah tougher parenting and evidence
those are the things that i missed from
my childhood evidence
yeah you mean due process right somebody
says something happened and then someone
else goes well i said it happened this
way like the old gumshoe shows then they
had to figure it out right
yeah that doesn't exist now on on social
media it's right so it's just frontier
justice right you feel how nervous
everybody just got in here the fact that
i just suggested that there should be
due process
this guy's talking crazy man did he just
join isis
[Applause]
that they agreed but they were they
didn't agree when it counted we cannot
we'll digitally add wu's don't worry
uh we have the woo machine uh
you are way too angry 50 is still
relatively young
you're you have the anger of a 110 year
old man
all these telephones
i i can't argue you can't argue i can't
argue that you know in the last segment
you're you know you're there's a lot you
get worked up about you know and you've
always been that way i've known you a
long time you get worked up about stuff
you're getting happy when he was four he
was like things were better when i was
three
world's [ __ ] now
the hay days are my twos
guilty as charged yeah oh so here's the
thing here's the thing are you now that
you're playing madison square garden
you've got all these fans you're
extremely successful uh comedian are you
able to enjoy your success now are you
able to just
have some fun with the fact that you're
a success yes yes i enjoy it but i still
you know the bane of my existence is i
let little things
bother me downloading new operating
systems will just you know i bring a lot
of tension into the house according to
my wife yeah
yeah one thing i've noticed we're always
working on me
you know
like my wife is evidently some completed
work like under museum glass and i'm
like that
building that has scaffolding around it
for like seven
years no she is she's a saint for
putting up with me i i know but like my
latest thing that's driving me nuts is i
spent 20 years in the back of the plane
getting treated like an animal and i
finally worked my way up to the front of
the plane group one which means you get
to board like it's your plane right
right
you get to board yes yeah you sit in a
chair that's the size for a human being
there's a place for your bag yep yep
right you get a little hot towel and all
and then the second i get that all of a
sudden now there's like these 20 groups
that are like pre-boarding now like half
the plane qualifies and they're getting
on and i just sit there just like losing
my [ __ ] you know
it starts off like it's just like
anybody in uniform anybody in the
military so it's like all right all
right but after like the 20th guy you
just start being like have you seen
action
it's anybody anybody with kids anybody
with disabilities and then just anybody
with a red shirt hey it's it's tony
tuesday anybody named anthony can get on
dude i sat one time
i saw this guy get on the plane okay he
wasn't in uniform he didn't have kids he
had all his limbs he wasn't limping he
didn't have a cough he just walked on
the plane it's like who the [ __ ] is that
guy
how did i get on before that guy
so
no i always hated the anxiety of being
in the back of the plane i just remember
like the worst is whenever you would get
your seat and you'd sit there and about
ready to close the door and you'd have
that empty seat next to you like the
poor man's first class you're like oh
[ __ ] i'll bring the armrest up i can
actually just be great and then all of a
sudden some fat bastard gets on the
black rock and you're like no no
you literally
you're like quint at the end of jaws
like sliding on
i swear to god this is all true
this dude got on he was so fat he was
sitting next to me i was literally next
to him and behind him
he's like tried to make himself smaller
and he like folded his arm and his lat
came out like like a you know those old
western saloon things
[Laughter]
so yeah so yeah that that motivates you
to try to get you all these years 20
years you work your way up to the front
and now still they won't let you uh now
that fat guy's considered disabled
because he can't stop eating
so he gets on look at me groaning 90 of
the world is starving to death that guy
eat a salad and get on the treadmill
like the rest of us we're all working
out what is the problem
[Applause]
well okay what could you do could you do
anything then could you get on the plane
is there anything you could do
i imagine there's something that i could
be doing there's always something that i
could be doing that's what i've learned
being married you know well you should
have done it this way
i'm sorry that that's something so i'm
your wife right now yeah that was just
playing in the loop uh what am i doing
now you know this is the thing you know
what it kills me it's just like if i
could just fix my
temper my wife she'd have nothing on me
yeah she got nothing on me
i work my ass off and make a great
living i like doing the dishes i'm a
great dad all she has on me is just it's
just i don't know like oh my overall
vibe
that's it wait
all she has on you is my it's your
overall personality and vibe you know
what kills me
i was this guy the essence of who you
are is the only thing yeah but i was
this guy when she met me
yeah she's acting like i changed i was
always flipping up
were you flipping out the day like when
you met did you flip out did you really
that is i remember she told me to go see
that movie monster
remember that movie with charlize theron
yeah yeah yeah and everybody was saying
how uh oh my god it was unbelievable
like they literally blamed guys that she
was a serial killer yeah you know what i
mean like when you saw the jeffrey
dahmer movie it wasn't like ah somebody
shoved the tuna fish sandwich up my ass
and i confused people with food so i
like did he make like a big excuse for
him
you know
she was a psycho killing people and she
should have died but i'm like watching
it feeling guilt
do they ever take responsibility for
their actions even when they're
murdering people it's somehow our fault
it's it's unreal
[Applause]
why would having a tuna fish sandwich
shoved up your butt make you want to eat
people because another man did it
right so it's another person so you
equate it i don't know sex with food i
figured i forget how the idea went but i
know is she laughed
when i said it she was dying laughing
and kind of saw my point
and um
i always hate when she says to me she'd
just be like you know i just don't see
where is that coming from where is that
coming from it says like honey how many
childhood stories do i have to tell you
before you follow the breadcrumbs to the
psycho that you're married i mean did
you ever take a psychology class like
you didn't see this coming right that's
what it is it's not that she says that
i'm a jerk it's just the nerve to be
surprised
[Laughter]
all right i wish we had more time uh
good god all right i feel like do i help
you at all by getting oh this is
cathartic it's cathartic because i'm
going to go home she's not going to
watch this she's over me
i love it when a guest says no one's
just she's not going to watch no she's
not going to watch it yeah yeah you can
see bill on his latest nationwide tour
50. and he's starting to mellow i swear
to god
i am i'm getting the twinkle in my eye
back at the td at the td garden in
boston on october 5th and madison square
garden wow on wednesday november 7.
that's fantastic unbelievable
for more cities and dates thank you go
to billburr.com
billboard we're right back